the dam is with us and a Seattle is it
as a dam is that correct yes that is
correct
how are you Dave better than I deserve
what's up well anyway I have a little
bit of a dilemma here I was following
your program for a couple of years now
and we've actually reached a point where
we are pretty close to being debt-free
except the mortgage good and I just got
excited and I kind of went out to get
any truck I've been averaging to pay tax
that's probably the channel Evan
thousands in the past couple years and I
thought the tax breaks are worth getting
a new truck so I didn't pay it off I'm
gonna have a payment of course but I'm
just trying to ask if it's a good idea
or not well you know the answer for that
well I just want to consider the
benefits the tax benefits if I'm
coughing up extra taxes every year and I
just gotta do drugs don't give you a tax
benefit well I'm a contractor so I'm
getting a I'm getting a tax break I've
been this write off basically yeah what
do you like a year take home is around
65 to 70 okay and so you're in a what a
probably a 15 percent tax bracket in the
year 2018 and so for every ten thousand
dollars you spent you saved fifteen
hundred dollars how is that smart well
this year has been a pretty good year so
I'm kind of oh you misunderstood let me
try again for every ten thousand dollars
you spend it saves you 1500 in taxes
okay that does not equate to smart okay
that means up another question then
there's the new lot where I can write
off up to eighteen thousand dollars on
depreciation for this current year yeah
so if I can write off exercise you're
going to borrow eighteen
thousand dollars to create an $18,000
write-off dude you gotta stop playing
these games you're gonna be broke your
whole life doing that crap so no no no
no no a write-off is not smart it's not
you don't do stuff for tax reasons it
never equals a hundred cents on the
dollar
ever and so I know the new law and run a
business so no I mean you do whatever
you want to do okay that that's that's
what you get the day you called me and
asked me after you said I'm working your
plan and and so no no you know what I'm
gonna teach you to do is the shortest
path to wealth and no one has ever
gotten wealthy going tax breaks made me
wealthy
that's complete BS tax breaks don't make
you wealthy there's not a chance of that
you wanted a dadgum truck that's all it
is and you went and bought a dadgum
truck and now you're trying to figure
out some way that that's smart when you
had to borrow money to buy the dadgum
truck and so no there's not a way that
that's going to turn into smart there's
not a there's not a there's no no amount
of mental or mathematical gymnastics
that you're gonna be able to do that
creates smart out of this so no no you
shouldn't have done that and yes you
need to sell it and whatever else I mean
thanks for the call open phones at
Triple Eight eight two five five two two
five there's always a way you can
rationalize stuff folks you can always
figure out a way to talk yourself into
something being smart but the things
that some of the most profound and
sophisticated things that you'll ever do
or understand in your life are very easy
to understand they're just hard to do
things like tell the truth
you know what today and you can skirt it
you can figure out a way around it
love your neighbor well I'm doing this
to let them know you're just not loving
them that's when it comes down to you
just don't have the bones but love them
right right and yeah you can go borrow
money and try to figure out some way
it's sophisticated but it doesn't work
it doesn't work folks
[Music]